if you're at school or starting out at
uni and you're interested in going into
research it can be difficult to see how
you get from the level that you're at to
the level of a researcher like a
professor or a lecturer or a PhD student
the thing to remember of course is that
you're comparing yourself to somebody
who's got years of experience he's done
possibly dozens of works of research in
their career and it's like studying a
video game and you're comparing your
character that you've just made to the
character of somebody who's been playing
for years and has levelled up and has
got lots of sweet loot in the beginning
their character is just like yours in
this video suggests advice Anya pugach
I'm really sorry about pronounce your
name wrong in the comments on the
previous video I'm going to take you
through my leveling process and talk you
through all the works of research that I
did in my career that took me from being
a level 1 scrub to a level 80 PhD
students if you're a researcher or a PhD
student watching this then please if
you're comfortable to do so do you
comment down there with your research
story with the research projects that
you've done along the way and how you
feel like you've developed on your
leveling process my research story
begins in my starting area which was my
school and my first quest I guess in
this framework which was my extended
project qualification or EPQ which I did
in year 12 on manned missions to Mars
and why they're so much more difficult
than manned missions to the moon this
was the first time that I've worked
towards a qualification that was outside
of a set syllabus there was a syllabus
we had to hit and certain things you had
to do in order to get you know given the
certain grade but I was allowed to pick
what I wanted to research and that was
really cool I think almost immediately I
latched on to this idea that if I had an
idea I could pursue it I could actually
pursue what I'm interested in rather
than just you know following what
someone else tells me to do maybe that
was what kind of kicked me off into
doing research as a career
I was trusted to work on my own
completely independently plan my own
time plan how I was going to write the
whole thing up plan even how I was going
to structure literally from beginning to
end it was my baby and I really loved
that process and I also enjoyed the
process of supervision where you were
doing the work yourself but you had
somebody who was experienced in the
field well not in the field of man's
mission to Mars but somebody who's
experienced in the field of Education
who could help you with
icing it up and advise you but not tell
you what to do just give you a helping
hand along the way and I feel like I
much preferred that relationship in
education to just being taught so again
maybe that's something else that sort of
kick-started me down doing academia
which is just as well because it only
got more and more frequent as to who's
went on so that first project basically
taught me how to be a student outside of
a curriculum and outside of school and
follow what I was interested in and
elements of that came in really useful
in my second research project so I
between the two events I got into Oxford
I did two years of studying physics
Oxford and then in the summer of my
second year I got an internship at an
engineering company in which I was
investigating failures of light emitting
diodes so these tiny electrical
components that they'd have I think four
failures out of 10,000 products sold so
wasn't exactly a pressing issue but they
wanted to investigate it so approaching
the whole thing like a scientist I came
up with a hypothesis which was that the
product that the LEDs were being used in
was running too hot and that was what
was causing the failure so I constructed
an experiment I designed this thing
which we built in the lab where we
heated a dye which we knew was working
and looked at the spectrum that it
produced so to determine when the
temperature affected the spectrum and so
if we looked at the the four failed
products that we had if the spectra
rated by the LEDs in them was different
to what we you know saw from an optimal
product which it was but in a way that
wasn't consistent with the data that I
got from my experiment so we ruled out
the idea that it was a temperature
problem so in a way the research project
was a failure but it kind of wasn't a
null result is still a result you know
it's something to cross off the list and
more importantly from my perspective it
was a real thrill to again be given the
autonomy but to be able to design a
whole experiment say this is a problem
here's a hypothesis let's let's work it
out you know to actually take the idea
that you know you learn in what year
seven to say hypothesis observations
analysis conclusions and evaluations and
actually translate that into a real-life
experiment I designed an Iran that was
amazing the experience was also useful
in another way because it taught me that
I didn't want to work in that kind of
role work
if other company was fine you know the
people were lovely but I couldn't see
myself working you know in a 95 job for
just churning out in some soulless
machine it wasn't for me so that kind of
pushed me further down the road of
academia and the really crucial step
came in my third research project so
I've leveled up some more I was a year
older I've done a year more physics so I
gained a chasm all levels specifically
leveling up atmospheric physics so I got
a first in the module at Oxford doing
geophysical fluid dynamics which was
what I eventually ended up specialising
in and I emailed a bunch of professors
universities saying look I'm interested
in doing a PhD possibly I want to see if
it's for me so do you have any work I
could do over the the summer break that
were useful to you and you know a low
allow me to see what doing a PhD is like
very fortunately a researcher in the
middle atmospheric group came back to me
was like yeah I've got a project you can
work on which was basically replicating
the results of the scientific paper and
running the analysis again but instead
of using data from the actual atmosphere
like from satellites we were working
with data from various climate models so
we were trying to work out which models
captured this behavior that we were
investigating which if you're interested
was the face synchronization of the
qualifier Niall and the semiannual
oscillations in the middle atmosphere
and donors projected a lot of things for
me firstly it confirmed that I wanted to
do a PhD secondly it was my first real
foray into learning house program I had
previously done a little bit of C and in
my second research project I did some
work in Excel which you should never do
for data analysis this time round I
taught myself
IDL which was programming language that
the original program for the analysis
from real climate data was written in
and it's not something few since but it
was my first foray into real scientific
programming so it was an immensely
useful skill to take on that early it
was also my first real experience
reading scientific literature so reading
a scientific paper and knowing how it's
broken up what the language is like what
the figures are like and sort of just
getting used to how things are done
which became useful because the after
the work was done I wrote it up into a
scientific
paper which was like full-length paper
that we're going to submit to a journal
we ended up not submitting it because my
supervisor kind of rightly I hate to
admit it wasn't totally happy because in
our analysis where we ran the original
data through we got a wiggle in a graph
a very small wiggle that wasn't there in
the first place and so he was reluctant
to publish it but I did get to present
the work at a conference in Germany so
that was another first and the whole
concept of rejecting it because of a
tiny quibble definitely taught me a lot
about academic rigor and while it taught
me a lot about managing your time and
not getting stressed if you turn up at
10:00 rather than 9:00 because you're in
charge of your own time you just stay
until 6:00 instead of 5:00 and it taught
me about working independently and
managing data and learning how like
programming computing structures work at
universities the most important thing
that this research project taught me was
I wanted to do a PhD it's like from that
perspective it was a total success I was
like yeah I love the autonomy I loved
being able to you know choose what I do
on a daily basis I'm given a project
with a little bit of supervision who my
supervisor with me you know once or
twice a week I go to his office and just
talk through what I was doing I loved it
I totally fell for the lifestyle I knew
it was what I wanted to do but before I
could do a PhD I had to do my Master's
project which was my fourth year Oxford
so only a couple of levels more that I
picked up over the over that quest and
my Master's project was on linear
stochastic models of global climate
which are a terrible idea I mean my
master's thesis basically went can you
build a linear stochastic model of
climate the answer was yes but it's
awful in many ways this project was like
a carbon copy of the one I just done I
had to learn another programming
language which was MATLAB I had to learn
how to submit tasks to a central
computer server rather than running them
locally you know lots of computer bits
and bobs that they you wouldn't learn
otherwise and it also taught me to write
up in a scientific format again instead
of a paper this time though it was a
master's thesis which I think off the
top of my head was like 40 pages long so
it was quite a meaty thing and I also
had to defend that thesis in a mini
viber
which was a conversation with two
academics I hadn't I remember distinctly
being asked a question
and just totally freezing and doing the
classic I'll can you can you repeat that
question so I didn't quite catch it when
I full well held it I was one more time
to think about it so I guess it taught
me something about academics
skullduggery as well but this was like
another step improvement like a small
increment I was getting slightly better
at programming and slightly better at
doing the maps that was involved and
working with the computing working with
a research team and you know submitting
reports to the supervisor and then
actually my supervisors boss because I
was now working within like a research
group structure with other researchers
which were all fantastically useful
skills to have because I ended up doing
the PhD here at Exeter so this is my
biggest and most recent quest actually
this this is like my quest log this is
the plan to my thesis ignore chapter 5
I'm working on it and doing a PhD relies
on all the skills I've learned up until
now and really quite importantly it's
not just one big project the whole point
of doing this organization structure was
to break down the PhD into smaller sub
projects and see how they fit together
because it's a three or four year now
more commonly qualification where you
will do little sub research projects
because a PhD generally has two to three
scientific papers worth of content in it
you will inevitably do sort of lots of
bits of analysis that don't always fit
kind of together there has to be a
structure separating them and also some
of those projects are going to be
failures I spent the best part of the
year working on something that isn't
going to go on my thesis because it just
turned out we can solve this particular
equation we don't actually know if it is
possible but I didn't have the time to
solve it so it's only through doing
those sub projects where you have tried
and failed and you've implemented all
the skills that you've used
you know from stretching railway back to
year 12 that you can start planning a
thesis and you can start you know
considering getting that final
qualification and that was the point I
want to make with this video that the
skills necessary to be told that you're
going to write a 200 page document about
original scientific research and not
find that terrifying only come after
years of incremental improvements and
learning through other research projects
nobody's born able to do it which means
that with dedication the right
qualifications and a hell of a lot of
training
so you can do it too now as I mentioned
at the start this is only my story if
you are a researcher please do comment
down there with the story that you've
gone on and the dragon's views laying
along the way because I mean I'll be
interested to hear from you
but I think it's important to show the
audience that there's no one way to
become a research there's no one correct
order to learn all these skills in that
there's lots of different parts to
becoming a PhD student or a professor
thank you to sonia for suggesting this
video idea thank you for watching and if
you did enjoy it consider giving it a
like or a share and if you have any
suggestions about topics that you'd like
me to talk about when it comes to
academia and you know doing a PhD please
feel free to suggest those down in the
comments as well thank you for watching
and I will see you in the next video